[Applause]
no
you heard him finagling about the death
pack
we got a couple of things working all
right chelsea you're trying to [ __ ]
pin me down
he could have died in a yacht explosion
12 years ago
he seizes that he calls him larry who
knows it's [ __ ]
gonna give him away these guys
just nod your head like michael caine at
the end of batman i'm so
i'm so funny i'm so used to talking to
him who can't follow anything or ask
follow-up questions
and schultzy finally started to pin me
down no i'm so curious so what happened
uh but there was a family business with
uh my dad my brother and myself and then
i
what type of business uh mechanical
contracting okay i knew it was
construction of some kind
yeah um and uh you know
i kind of i left to go do comedy it was
my brother my dad and things soured
drastically were you like the referee
between them usually
the la i was like the final round of
like hey this is you know whatever
um i would made the final call and then
he was just like my dad was like yeah
whatever i was like all right
see ya so then him and your brother just
couldn't they haven't talked
at all and you side with your bro on
this one yeah i got it i mean you know
the way i look i was like if he could
you know if he could screw him over
like i'm here so wait your dad screwed
your bro
over potentially potentially yeah in a
fictional world that we're living in on
this podcast
this is on patreon right what the [ __ ]
oh we want it shout out to patreon.com
so okay so then you guys you side with
your bro obviously
that makes perfect sense and your dad's
relationship with your brother source
that soured first right and then i was
like hey as i was already outside of you
know i was outside looking in like hey
guys whatever you know let's try it and
it just
it wasn't you know not not salvageable i
think it's it's reconcilable differences
we should
say but here yeah and i think it's like
it's hard for reconcilable differences
it's funny
yeah the ones that you can yeah yeah
yeah but no but it's it's tricky like
you want it though with parents right
where it's like um
we can't fathom that we're not the most
important things to them
and it's like really hard for a lot of
people to accept yeah when when we're
not
and i think that usually breaks a
relationship because we go well if i'm
not the most important thing to you
then you don't love me sure because
that's like it's all or nothing kind of
it's all or nothing right but like um
i don't know like i've spoken to folks
i'll keep their names private obviously
but uh
and they basically told me that i would
rather have some relationship with my
dad
than zero relationships with my dad but
very mature
this is so mature like getting there to
that point i was like baffles like how
can you even accept that
you're not the most important thing yeah
to me it's like you're not garbage
when you're garbage yeah we're trapped
like yeah i think for me it's like if
you argue
if you argue with a family member like
my my girl will argue with her parents
or like whatever brother they'll get
like you know just whatever yeah and i'm
like
oh to me a reality because my family's
all so [ __ ] up and every you know it's
like
there is a possibility that you're never
going to speak to that person again like
every time you argue yeah i don't
so i go like i'm like yeah there's been
times i'm like arguing with my brother
or my sister or my mom or
[ __ ] you know anna i'm like oh this
could end in like to the point where
like
christmas is going to be weird for five
years i think you and i talked about
kimmy and i weirdly related on a lot of
stuff
yeah yeah yeah both we didn't know there
was a such thing as healthy fighting
now that blew my [ __ ] mind that you
just fight and it's fine like
you say something you're trying to hurt
i'm just learning to understand that
yeah yeah i'm just learning to
understand
that a fight in my mind this is always
everything is on the line
every fight yeah you left the [ __ ]
food out okay here we go here's your
[ __ ] 12 rounds something's going to
be said that's not going to be able to
be taken back that's a [ __ ] that
that's where the garbage comes in yeah
yeah yeah yeah like it's possible for
just to be like that person is
completely wiped out of my
life forever that's my wife's like
that's insane i'm like well that's
reality and that happens a lot i mean
like yeah there's you know
like an aunt or something i mean like my
dad i haven't talked to my dad and like
i haven't had a relationship with my dad
in seven
i don't know seven years and i think
that's why we work so well together
because normally like i said like if i'm
arguing i go to say the worst thing ever
right and but with him i know that
there's a little bit of a governor on it
you know anything like he can keep me in
check because
like if this guy [ __ ] doesn't talk to
his dad he's not gonna have any problems
yeah i'd say so i said
i got no problem you dude i'm like like
i'm like dude i could delete your number
and close the door
convenience store i saw him in the wawa
parking lot a couple of months ago
that's
no way yeah that's garbage [ __ ] iced
them your dad
can you men ice in the veins daddy oh
right by him not easily
touch shoulders he was like coming out
of the car and i was
walking like i was parked over here he
was here and i came out of the store
this way so like
did he see you oh yeah and was there any
acknowledgement i mean it probably broke
his heart man
didn't stop and say anything yeah yeah
cause he's a [ __ ] proud guy
you know two [ __ ] irish [ __ ]
potatoes well it is man
you guys gonna just figure it out in
heaven i mean i don't know
either one of those maybe hell i don't
know if we're both making it to heaven
yo can i just say i saw my dad in a wawa
parking lot
i haven't garbage my dad in a while
parking lots pure garbage
that's a different level yeah seeing a
full loaf of bread that's real
your parents are separated but do does
she try to
kind of like reignite that relationship
with your pops
my mom yeah oh no between you and your
pops does she recognize or she's like no
you made the right decision yeah no she
was out on him in the [ __ ] eighties
she was like yeah this you know andrews
okay so back to the future and she was
like i'm done
it's over yeah we're talking real
psychos
that's the crazy thing man it's like and
i don't know anything about your family
but
it's so weird that like when people have
kids i don't know if you if you like
feel this way but like when i see
someone who has a kid
i immediately respect them more because
i'm like oh you have real responsibility
yeah like
there's a life in your hands yeah dude
and that's the thing about these zoom
calls like even when we were working on
the on the special right
we would have these zoom calls and
there'd be people like busting their ass
on this [ __ ] show
and then you'd hear their kids in the
background and after that like
i'll be honest if somebody's like
[ __ ] up a little bit i can be hard on
people yeah
because i have really high expectations
i give the most praise i'd say they're
the most amazing people in the world but
if i feel like you're being lazy or
you're just not putting the effort in
like i'll i'll lay it i'll [ __ ] lay
in
and it can get crazy it can get a little
crazy but when i hear they have kids and
[ __ ] like that immediately i'm like
hey man you guys should do what if
there's people who have no [ __ ] kids
crying in the background and they're not
getting their job done then obviously
you're just [ __ ] up
but there's something about that where
like oh you're like a fully formed adult
and then you realize as we become adults
and start seeing our parents as actual
human beings we're like
oh anybody could have kids yeah yeah
yeah yeah anybody yeah
there's no there's a barrier to entry is
minimum you need a license to get
like be a barber yeah
is very difficult incredibly difficult i
look back on my parents and i'm like i i
don't know how my dad didn't walk the
[ __ ] out
from your mom just in the situation what
was this it was am i just i'm saying the
couple at 870 sitting on the couch
any general family where you have you
know a mom and a dad who
you know working class family or working
when
then you have two kids three free then
you have two kids
you know that might be close and aged
together like two brothers that are
[ __ ]
you know type a kind of guys you know
that that are playing sports fighting
with each other
all that [ __ ] anything like that it's
like i don't know how they [ __ ] do it
you